Quand j'avais 14 ans, j'étais intéressée par les sciences,
fascinée par elles, je voulais en apprendre plus.
Et j'avais un professeur de science au lycée qui disait à la classe :
« Les filles n'ont pas besoin d'écouter. »
Encourageant, oui je sais...
(Rires)
J'ai choisi de ne pas écouter... mais seulement cette phrase.
Alors laissez-moi vous emmener dans la cordillère des Andes au Chili,
500 kilomètres au nord-est de Santiago.
C'est très reculé, très sec, et très beau.
Et il n'y a pas grand-chose.
Il y a des condors, des tarentules,
et à la tombée de la nuit quand la lumière diminue,
ça révèle un des ciels les plus noirs de la planète.
C'est un peu magique comme endroit, la montagne.
C'est une combinaison merveilleuse de sommets très reculés
et de technologies délicieusement complexes.
Et nos ancêtres, dès les débuts de ce qu'on connaît de l'Histoire,
ont regardé le ciel de nuit et ont songé à la nature de notre existence.
Notre génération ne fait pas exception.
La seule difficulté est que le ciel, la nuit, est maintenant caché
par la lumière des villes.
Les astronomes vont donc dans ces montagnes très reculées,
pour regarder et étudier le cosmos.
Les télescopes sont nos fenêtres vers le cosmos.
Ce n'est pas une exagération de dire que l'hémisphère Sud sera
le futur de l'astronomie du XXIème siècle.
Nous avons déjà une collection de télescopes existants,
dans la cordillère des Andes au Chili, qui sera bientôt complétée
par une collection sensationnelle de nouvelles capacités.
Il y aura deux groupes internationaux qui construiront
des télescopes géants, sensibles aux radiations optiques, comme nos yeux.
On aura des télescopes de surveillance
qui scanneront le ciel toutes les deux ou trois nuits.
Il y aura des télescopes radio,
sensibles aux ondes longue portée qu'émettent les radios.
Et puis il y aura des télescopes dans l'espace.
Il y aura un successeur au télescope spatial Hubble ;
il sera appelé le télescope James Webb,
et sera lancé en 2018.
Il y aura un satellite appelé TESS
qui découvrira des planètes en dehors de notre système solaire.
Pendant la dernière décennie, je guidais un groupe...
un consortium... un groupe international,
qui construit ce qui sera, une fois qu'il sera terminé,
le plus grand télescope optique ayant jamais existé.
Il s'appelle le Télescope Géant Magellan, ou TGM.
Ce télescope aura des miroirs qui feront 8,4 mètres de diamètre...
chacun.
J'ai bien dit 8,4 mètres.
Cela couvre cette scène... probablement jusqu’au quatrième rang.
Chacun des sept miroirs dans ce télescope
fera 8,4 mètres de diamètre.
Ensemble, les miroirs de ce télescope feront à peu près
25 mètres de diamètre.
Donc, environ la taille de cet auditorium.
Le télescope en entier fera à peu près 43 mètres de haut,
et j'ajoute que, étant à Rio,
certains d'entre vous doivent avoir vu la statue géante du Christ.
Leur taille est comparable en hauteur.
En fait, la statue est plus petite que ne sera le télescope.
C'est comparable à la taille de la Statue de la Liberté.
Et il sera rangé dans une enceinte qui fait 22 étages...
60 mètres de haut.
Mais c'est un bâtiment inhabituel pour un télescope.
Il aura des fenêtres ouvertes sur le ciel,
et sera capable de pointer vers le ciel,
et sera, en fait, capable de pivoter sur sa base...
2 000 tonnes de bâtiment qui pivotent.
Le Télescope Géant Magellan aura 10 fois la résolution
du télescope spatial Hubble.
Il sera 20 millions de fois plus sensible que l’œil humain.
Et il est possible que, pour la première fois, il trouve de la vie sur des planètes
en dehors du système solaire.
Il nous permettra de regarder en arrière et de voir la 1ère lumière de l'univers
-- littéralement, l'aurore du cosmos.
L'aube cosmique.
C'est un télescope qui nous permettra de regarder en arrière,
d'être témoin de l'état des galaxies lorsqu'elles s'assemblaient,
le premier trou noir de l'univers, les premières galaxies.
Voilà, pendant des milliers d'années, nous avons étudié le cosmos,
nous nous sommes interrogés sur notre place dans l'univers.
Les Grecs anciens nous disaient
que la Terre était le centre de l'Univers.
Il y a 500 ans, Copernic déplaça la Terre,
et mit le soleil au centre du Cosmos.
Et, comme nous l'avons vu au fil des siècles
depuis que Galilée, le scientifique italien,
a tourné, à cette époque, un très petit télescope, de 5 centimètres, vers le ciel,
à chaque fois que nous avons construit de grands télescopes,
nous avons appris quelque chose sur l'univers ;
nous avons toujours fait des découvertes, sans exception.
Au XXème siècle, nous avons appris que l'Univers était en expansion
et que notre système solaire n'était pas le centre de cette expansion.
Nous savons aujourd'hui que l'Univers est constitué d'environ
100 milliards de galaxies, visibles à notre échelle
et chacune de ces galaxies contient 100 milliards d'étoiles.
Nous regardons maintenant la plus profonde image du cosmos
jamais prise.
Elle a été prise en utilisant le télescope spatial Hubble,
en le pointant vers ce qui était, auparavant, une portion de ciel vide,
avant le lancement d'Hubble.
Et si vous pouvez imaginer que cette petite zone
n'est qu'un cinquantième de la taille de la pleine lune.
Si vous pouvez imaginer la pleine lune.
Il y a maintenant 10 000 galaxies visibles dans cette image.
Et la faible qualité ainsi que la petite taille de ces images n'est que le résultat
du fait que ces galaxies sont tellement loin, à de vastes distances.
Et chacune de ces galaxies peut contenir en son sein,
des milliards ou même des centaines de milliards d’étoiles individuelles.
Les télescopes sont des machines à remonter le temps.
Plus loin on regarde dans l'espace, plus loin on voit dans le temps.
Ils sont comme des seaux.
Littéralement, ils collectent la lumière.
Donc, plus le seau est large, plus le miroir est large,
plus on peut voir de lumière, et plus on peut voir loin en arrière.
Donc, dans le dernier siècle, nous avons appris
qu'il y a des objet exotiques dans l'Univers : les trous noirs.
Nous avons découvert la matière noire et l'énergie noire
que nous ne pouvons voir.
Vous regardez maintenant une véritable image de matière noire.
(Rires)
Vous avez compris, tous les publics ne comprennent pas.
Donc, la manière de déduire la présence de matière noire :
on ne peut pas la voir, mais il y a une traction caractéristique,
due à la gravité.
Si nous regardons dehors, nous pouvons voir cette mer de galaxies
dans un univers en expansion.
Ce que je fais, moi, c'est de mesurer l'expansion de l'univers,
et un des projets que j'ai effectués dans les années 90
utilisait le télescope Hubble pour mesurer la vitesse de l'expansion de l'Univers.
Nous pouvons maintenant retracer 14 milliards d'années.
On a appris au cours du temps que les étoiles ont des histoires propres :
elle naissent, atteignent un âge moyen
certaines d'elles ont même des morts dramatiques.
Et les braises de ces étoiles forment les nouvelles étoiles que l'on voit,
la plupart ayant des planètes qui tournent autour d'elles.
Et un des résultats vraiment surprenants des 20 dernières années
a été la découverte d'autres planètes, tournant autour d'autres étoiles.
Elles sont appelées exoplanètes.
Avant 1995, nous n'étions pas conscients de l’existence même d'autres planètes,
autres que celles tournant autour de notre Soleil.
Mais à présent, il y a presque 2000 autres planètes orbitant autour d'autres étoiles
que nous pouvons détecter, et en mesurer la masse.
Il y a 500 de celles-ci qui sont des systèmes de plusieurs planètes.
Et il y a 4 000 (pour l'instant) d'autres candidats
pour être des planètes orbitant autour d'étoiles.
Elles arrivent en une quantité déroutante de variétés.
Il y a des planètes comme Jupiter, qui sont chaudes,
il y en a qui sont gelées, il y a des mondes faits d'eau,
il y a des planètes rocheuses comme la Terre appelées «super-Terre»,
et il y a des planètes qui pourraient être des mondes de diamants.
On sait qu'il y a au moins une planète, notre Terre, où il y a de la vie.
Nous avons même trouvé des planètes orbitant autour de deux étoiles.
Ce n'est désormais plus de la science-fiction.
Autour de la Terre, on sait qu'il y a de la vie,
nous avons développé une vie complexe,
nous pouvons maintenant interroger nos origines.
Et étant donné ce qu'on a découvert, des chiffres impressionnants suggèrent
qu'il peut y avoir des milliers, peut-être des centaines de milliers,
d'autres [planètes] assez proches,
juste à la bonne distance de leurs étoiles,
pour qu'il y ait l'existence d'eau liquide et qui pourraient abriter la vie.
Nous nous émerveillons devant les probabilités écrasantes,
et la chose incroyable, c'est que dans la prochaine décennie,
le TGM sera peut-être capable d’enregistrer
le spectre d'atmosphère de ces planètes,
et déterminer si, oui ou non, elles pourraient abriter la vie.
Alors, quel est le projet TGM?
C'est un projet international.
Qui inclut l'Australie, la Corée du Sud, et je suis contente de pouvoir dire,
étant à Rio, que le nouveau partenaire de notre télescope est le Brésil.
(Applaudissements)
Cela inclut aussi un nombre d'institutions à travers les États-Unis,
incluant Harvard,
le Smithsonian et Carnegie,
et les Universités d'Arizona, de Chicago, de Texas-Austin et de Texas A&M.
Cela implique aussi le Chili.
La création des miroirs dans ce télescope
est tellement fascinante en elle-même.
Prenez des bouts de verre, faites-les fondre dans un fourneau qui tourne.
Ceci se passe sous un stade de foot
dans l'Université d'Arizona.
C'est placé sous 52 000 sièges.
Personne ne sait que cela se produit.
Et il y a un chaudron tournant.
Les miroirs sont moulés et refroidis très lentement,
et puis sont polis avec une précision incroyable.
Donc, si vous réfléchissez à la précision de ces miroirs,
les bosses sur un miroir, sur ceux de plus de 8 mètres,
font moins d'un millionième de pouce.
Alors, pouvez-vous visualiser ça ?
Aie !
(Rires)
C'est un 5ème de millième de la largeur d'un de mes cheveux,
sur un total de plus de 8 mètres.
C'est une réussite spectaculaire.
C'est ce qui nous permettra d'avoir cette précision.
Et qu'est-ce que cette précision nous offre ?
Le TGM, si vous pouvez l'imaginer...
si je tenais une pièce, ce que, en fait, j'ai,
et que je regardais la face de la pièce,
je peux voir d'ici les marques sur la pièce, le visage de cette pièce.
Je pense que même les gens du premier rang ne peuvent le voir.
Mais si vous tourniez le TGM,
la totalité des 25 mètres de diamètre que nous voyons dans cet auditorium,
et que nous regardions à 300 kilomètres,
si je me trouvais à São Paulo, on pourrait voir le visage sur cette pièce.
C'est ça la résolution et le pouvoir extraordinaire de ce télescope.
Et si nous étions...
(Applaudissements)
Si un astronaute allait sur la Lune, à 400 000 kilomètres de nous,
et allumait une bougie, une seule bougie,
nous serions capables de la détecter, en utilisant le TGM.
Plutôt extraordinaire.
Ceci est une image simulée d'un amas de galaxies proche.
« Proche » étant astronomique, c'est relatif.
C'est à des dizaines de millions d'années-lumières.
Voilà à quoi cet amas ressemblerait.
Regardez ces quatre objets brillants,
et comparons-les maintenant avec la camera du télescope spatial Hubble.
Nous pouvons voir des détails flous commencer à apparaître.
Et finalement, (remarquez l'effet dramatique) voilà ce que le TGM verra.
Alors, regardez ces images une nouvelle fois.
Voilà ce que le télescope le plus puissant sur Terre voit,
et ça, encore une fois, c'est que le TGM verra.
Une précision extraordinaire.
Donc, où en sommes-nous ?
Nous avons maintenant nivelé le haut de la montagne au Chili.
Nous l'avons aplani.
Nous avons poli et testé le premier miroir.
Nous avons moulé le deuxième et troisième miroir.
Nous allons mouler le quatrième.
Nous avons eu des rapports cette année,
de conférences internationales qui ont parlé de nous,
et qui ont dit : « Vous êtes prêt à construire ».
Nous planifions de construire le télescope avec les 4 premiers miroirs.
Nous voulons que ce soit fait rapidement, et collecter des données scientifiques --
de ce que nous, les astronomes appelons la « première lumière », en 2021.
Et le télescope complet sera fini au milieu de la prochaine décennie,
avec les sept miroirs.
Nous sommes maintenant prêts à regarder l'Univers lointain,
l'aube cosmique.
Nous serons capables d'étudier d'autres planètes en détail.
Mais pour moi, l'une des choses les plus excitantes
à propos de la construction du TGM
est l'opportunité de pouvoir découvrir quelque chose
que nous ne connaissons pas, que nous ne pouvons même pas imaginer,
quelque chose de complètement nouveau.
Et j'ai espoir qu'avec la construction de ce centre, ainsi que d'autres,
beaucoup de jeunes hommes et femmes auront envie d'aller toucher les étoiles.
Merci beaucoup.
Obrigado.
(Applaudissements)
B. Giussani : Merci beaucoup, Wendy.
Restez avec moi, car j'ai une question pour vous.
Vous avez parlé de différents centres de recherche.
Donc le TGM se construit, mais aussi l'ALMA, et d'autres au Chili
et ailleurs, y compris Hawaï.
Le but est-il la coopération et la complémentarité ou bien la compétition ?
Je sais qu'il y a une compétition en termes de fonds, mais pour la science ?
W. Freedman : En termes de science, ils sont très complémentaires.
Les télescopes qui sont dans l'espace, ceux qui sont au sol,
avec des ondes et des capacités différentes,
ou même très similaires mais des instruments différents,
ils étudieront tous différents aspects de la question que l'on se pose.
Pour que, lors de la découverte d'autres planètes,
nous puissions tester ces observations, mesurer les atmosphères,
être capable de voir l'espace en très haute résolution.
Ils sont très complémentaires.
Oui, il y a concurrence pour les financements.
Mais scientifiquement, c'est très complémentaire.
BG : Wendy, merci beaucoup d'être venue à TEDGlobal.
WF : Merci.
(Applaudissements)